the force awakens DVD has a release date
and it's not may the fourth I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update while
it had been rumored for some time that
star wars force awakens might make its
home entertainment debut in April a
release date has not yet been officially
announced but now it seems that the DVD
and blu-ray of the blockbuster movie
will arrive in stores on April
eighteenth as reported by gamesradar.com
the date has been revealed via a poster
for Jura cell batteries in the UK the
poster depicts the brand's long-running
bunny mascot wielding a lightsaber with
the release date clearly displayed
underneath the date is yet to be
officially confirmed by Disney earlier
this week further details about what
fans can expect to find on the home
entertainment release were revealed as
reported by den of geek the Amazon page
for the discs lists several bonus
features including the table read
building BBA and deleted scenes in an
interview with The Independent newspaper
the film's editors Mary Jo Marky and
Marianne Brandon revealed that fans
could expect seven or eight deleted
scenes we have been talking about the
deleted scenes Brandon said but Disney
has mentioned to us that since they're
going to be DVD treats for viewers we
should stop talking about them there
aren't a lot there's one with Harrison
Ford there's on with Ray but there
aren't a lot will you be buying the DVD
or blu-ray anything in particular you're
hoping to see in the deleted scenes let
me know in the comments or come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot
you